el expresidente ejecutivo de Nissan
Motors reclama más de mil millones de
dólares al fabricante de automóviles
japonés y a las personas involucradas en
su destitución en 2018 de la compañía
arresto y encarcelamiento de 100 días en
Japón por malas prácticas financieras la
prensa libanesa ha difundido hoy la
noticia de esta demanda multimillonaria
a Nissan interpuesta por Carlos Ghost en
el tribunal de casación libanés cabe
recordar que el empresario de origen
libanés y prófugo de la justicia
japonesa huyó a finales de 2019 al
Líbano en una espectacular Fuga que ha
servido de guión cinematográfico desde
entonces Ghost se refugia en una de sus
viviendas en beirut ya que Líbano no
extradita a sus ciudadanos pero no puede
salir del país porque pesa sobre él una
orden de arresto
el expresidente de Nissan demanda daños
y perjuicios contra su persona por lo
que él considera acusaciones infundadas
o dicho en otras palabras Un complot
para sacarlo de la compañía después de
que él haya forjado el mayor acuerdo de
empresas automovilísticas del mundo
hasta ahora no ha habido ningún tipo de
reacción por parte de los directivos de
Nissan ni tampoco de las autoridades
judiciales de Japón la vista del juicio
está prevista para mediados de
septiembre pero se desconoce si el
sistema judicial japonés ayudará al
Líbano en la investigación